do we really have to go to the serious
thing about tulsi gabbard
okay fine i guess this one this one
actually kind of
bugs me out tulsi gabbard drops
defamation suit against hillary clinton
see now i was making jokes about this
months ago
like when when she her documentary
dropped
biden said i'm gonna pick a woman vp and
i was like
oh my gosh he's gonna pick hillary adam
spoke it into existence he's gonna pick
hillary guys
i'm just joking that's funny right
he manifested you manifested it bro oh
no what did i do
what have you done there was an article
in the in the hill
saying that there was going to be like a
hillary obama ticket or something
you saw that like the convention would
fall apart joe biden would
sunset or something and then i mean look
look
what like hillary and michelle or
hillary and barack
as a vp yep can is that legal i don't
know that's what they were arguing and
it's like
there have been a ton so first and
foremost right
they they keep putting out these stories
like she's running because they know it
it gets clicks when they do it yeah yeah
you know and so
i've actually backed off from make like
making this kind of content that's why i
didn't do it i didn't do it
in a standard news segment for my other
[ __ ] channel on this okay
because i'm like dude there's been so
much speculation about this
like i've been roped into like a story
will pop up and be like hillary does
these things she may be running and then
i'll do a video about it and be like oh
man
and then i'm like this is just click
bait like i'm there
you know i bring this up you know fairly
often like i can tell
that some stories are written with the
intent of getting people like me to show
the article and be like whoa
so i like i'm conscious of that if i do
a segment like that i'll point pointed
out like i know they're trying to bait
me into talking about their
their co their content or their their
platform or whatever yeah but i gotta i
gotta admit
this one's weird yeah exactly i was just
weird i i was a i'm a big fan of tulsi
right uh we know oh and
look i i uh in the end i was more for
andrew yang than
than tulsi yeah now i think the
democrats are just a waste of time and
this
and unfortunately i think this just adds
to it yeah this is total this is uh
leading right into what i was saying so
so tulsi was suing hillary clinton
because she said that hillary was like a
russian asset let's
let's read it fox news reports rep tulsi
gabbard dropped her defamation suit
against hillary clinton wednesday ending
a brief legal battle over comments
made by the former secretary of state
suggesting the congresswoman has ties to
russia
gabbard filed the 50 million dollar loss
after clinton said in an october 2019
interview
that one of the democratic presidential
contenders was the favorite of the
russians
and a russian asset gabbard who served
in the army national guard
was a presidential candidate at the time
isn't no she's currently a major isn't
she
she's not out issue i thought she's
reserves could be wrong reserves
i think so i mean look yeah she's still
serving was she yeah
she was a major clinton didn't mention
gabbard by name but her spokesman later
said if the nesting doll fits
in a court filing gabbard's lawyers
dismissed legal action
while they remain certain of the
action's legal merit they are just as
certain that this new covet and
post-covered world require them to focus
their time and attention on other
priorities including defeating donald
trump in 2020
rather than righting the wrongs here the
attorney said uh said according to the
hill
the lawsuit contended that clinton had
no basis for making her false assertions
gabbard claimed the former 2016
candidate had a unique personal
connection to tulsi
that animates her hostility toward tulsi
in her presidential campaign
she also claimed that clinton's
hostility stemmed from her support for
senator bernie sanders in 2016.
clinton was extremely angry to put it
mildly that tulsi endorsed senator
sanders
over her all right all right all right
the first thing is
let's be let's be calm rational and
reasonable people tulsi may have just
dropped this because the suit was was
bunk
like there you go and yet it's literally
saying right here
that it it isn't bunk it's not bunk
it's of course we have legal legal merit
for these actions
saving face i don't know that doesn't
seem
like they would throw that in there then
if that's the case saying someone is the
favorite of the russians is
clear opinion right and saying that she
was a russian asset
is i would say it's not clear but it is
opinion
so what was the whole point of doing it
in the first place opening the suit
against hillary
press yeah this is one of the biggest
complaints i had about tulsi is that she
leaned
too hard into these like hillary clinton
like hillary clinton called her caller
an asset tulsi made this
epic takedown tweet calling her what did
she what did she call her can you pull
it out that was amazing i'll find it
so uh uh tulsi called hillary like a
warmonger
yeah what what what did you call it scum
or something queen of scum yeah yeah
it was pulled up spicy all right it was
it was it wasn't it was an
it was a bomb it was a nuke and it was a
tactical new
so now there's a few things we can say
the suit
was for pr a lot of people thought it
was just a generate press because it did
get her name out there
i thought that was a bad idea i always
tell people these kinds of drop
drama attacks are are not good for for
like
trying to generate prestige or merit
behind your name okay
you know so but but maybe not maybe
you think hillary paid her off paid her
to do this they're here
take some money yeah they dropped the
suit 100
yeah i'm not saying i believe 100 i'm
saying it's you know you know
is it possible yes absolutely possible
that happened so we just saw
james damore who was suing google for
discrimination against
conservatives white people and and i
think asians okay he
dismissed his own suit his lawyer who's
i believe it was
k dylan who's like a very prominent like
you know uh
lawyer and they submitted saying we're
gonna we're gonna end this and this case
and everyone was like that's weird
and so my speculation is it's it's a way
of settling
without having the opponent the the
defendant admit defeat
so this case could literally be because
hillary clinton went to tulsi and they
were like we'll give you a million
dollars
and then but you have to dismiss the
case because a settlement is our
admission of guilt
right so then they go and say okay we're
done and the donald trump thing is an
easy excuse
exactly it's the easiest easiest yeah
for sure or
or maybe maybe you can't have
a lawsuit over hillary clinton's
defamation
if she's going to be grabbing the
nomination the last minute that's what i
was thinking
if the strategy of the democrats has
been to have joe biden be a
shield to placehold and absorb all of
the brunt of all the negative attacks
and all the cash
yeah and then at the last minute you
know he falls down some stairs or
hits his head or oh wait excuse me
excuse me falls down
some stairs okay in his case it might be
like actually falling down
all right just makes it more plausible
i'm just saying
if he's an old man and he can't run
anymore and then they're like
who do we have and everyone goes yay
hillary
tulsi gabbard can't scream yay hillary
if she's suing her for defamation
right and more importantly if they're
trying to avoid the negative press
this would pop up immediately yeah this
is really weird
quash suspect yeah wiped away it could
also be much more simple than that
just like hillary clinton's camp they
were like okay so when hillary
officially takes the nomination
in you know in in september what what
what are our liabilities
and this tulsi gabbard suits a liability
ask her what she wants
yeah and then they negotiated and they
cut a big paycheck come up with
something
but it depends if you think uh tulsi has
principles behind her and i don't like
this
i don't you know uh to be fair to be
fair though i mean tulsi may just run
out of money
it's also that simple that her lawyers
are like here's your bill 30 grand for
all the paperwork we've done so far
and then she's like i can't do this we
need to cut it yeah so how much to draft
that we're walking away from this
that makes sense too she's out of the
race she's not running for reelection
i don't know what her plan is moving
forward so i guess the the
the the more fun question is moving on
from the tulsi gabbard stuff
will hillary clinton be running
you mentioned something about her
appearing yeah yeah
right when as soon as biden said
i'm gonna pick a woman i was like oh man
i'm
making a joke blah blah hillary hillary
and then the next day i see her face
and when i turn the tv on it's just like
a big hillary face i'm like what the
heck is this
oh her brand new documentary just
dropped it's like oh
of course and then oh she's got a book
deal
and then a month later she's hosting a
town hall meeting
with joe biden and does all the talking
and i'm like
what is going on here she also did a
fundraiser without joe that
broke a record for what was the
fundraiser for the dnc
and like yeah it was like only so i was
reading and i could be wrong about this
because i don't have the article pulled
up but it was something like
it was a joint dnc plus like super pac
thing
meaning there was no spending limit and
so they ended up raising millions of
dollars
where if it was a direct thing with joe
biden then you have a
you have a limit from that you know
federal election i see that rule
because she's not actually running right
now that's another thing that people
don't
understand about why people why they
don't say they're running
right now you could go to goldman sachs
or some bank and say
that you can privately tell them i
really think i'm gonna run
it'd be great if i had you in my corner
wink
wink and then and then they go would you
like to do a paid speaking gig where we
pay you 10 million dollars to speak to
our employees and you go that would be
great thank you i will speak to your
employees for 10 million dollars
and then you shake hands and then they
they like go on the intercom
and they're like jerry come down to room
17 5.
and and then you're like how's it going
yo what's up all right we're good we're
good and you walk out and they go here's
your 10 million dollars
and then the next day you announce your
run yikes
and that was totally legal i mean i'm
really exaggerating here
right but that's what hillary was
accused of like everyone knew she was
going to run
and she was doing a round of speaking
engagements that paid hundreds of
thousands
back in like 2015 right yeah yeah yeah i
remember i mean there's also the fact
that like
dude you know what man how stupid is it
that you can be
working for the federal government like
the state department and have a
foundation that accepts money from
foreign interests that's really weird
it's like bribery in front of our faces
yeah
i don't like blatant dude and uh
and yeah the funny thing is when she
lost the clinton foundation donations
like tanked
oh really we all knew what that was for
yep and i talked to my friends about it
who like voted for and i'm like
don't you have any questions about like
okay okay for all i know
it's legitimate whatever i don't care
the point is like
why are foreign governments donating
millions of dollars to her foundation
while she's secretary of state or
whatever
yeah i don't know you know the response
i get from all these lefties is what huh
they don't know anything about i don't
know they don't even know about it
anything about it what a surprise
if i told you that was the case would
that strike you was odd that all i can
think of is what we were talking about
the left just reads the left stuff
yeah instead of they're being aware of
everything that's happening right
it's like they're doing research right
it's like the 4chan meme where they said
any sufficiently free speech like
unmoderate platform becomes right wing
because the left relies on a very
carefully crafted narrative
to protect them yeah like i think a
really good example of this is just like
i tweeted about uh new footage came out
in the george floyd case that shows he
wasn't resisting
at least in the way people would assume
for sure yeah and someone tweeted at me
this must be hard for you what that's
the world they live in
i'm like bro i'm like hardcore liberty
free speech
if the government's violating someone's
constitutional rights i get mad about it
right yeah like what do you what do you
what do you mean where do they get their
information from
it's just an assumption of they live
they live in this world
that isn't reality and even when i
tweeted something
and i'm thinking to myself i'm like bro
i just put out a tweet got like a
thousand
one thousand five hundred retweets
showing this guy being arrested not
resisting
yeah it uh messed up and and the
response from them is
they're mad at me yeah what like you're
insulting me like
take the win dude like what do you mean
if you think i'm this villain
shouldn't you just take the win yeah i
don't get it that's the world they live
in
yep so you can have hillary clinton you
can have obama gate
the most annoying thing to me though is
is there really are grifters man
yeah for those who are not familiar with
what a grifter is they accuse me of
being a grifter because i don't like
democrats and i'm like
yeah but like i don't and i talk about
it all the time like i think my feelings
are rooted in growing up in chicago
okay and being ripped off by corrupt
democrats all day every day
yeah and so like republicans weren't a
part of my life i never cared they
weren't like i don't know
whatever i disagree with you and so it
felt like i was being betrayed by those
who are supposed to be you know
fighting for me yeah that makes sense
and then it's also a combination of the
weird like let's just be honest man
joe biden the like the the like
everything about the democrats
in the past five or six years has been
just like wacky
insane agreed you know i'll be honest
though i like obama
really made me angry yeah because i was
like i'm gonna vote for this guy and
then he's like
and then as soon as he gets in office
like the first thing i'm gonna do blow
up some kids
and i was like what what
bro man what do you think is the higher
percentage of what's going to happen
hillary becomes a vp and then joe biden
dies
while in office or she takes his place
as a
nominee i think both are hypotheticals
not saying that this is going to happen
but what do you think
has the higher percentage of what what
would happen which would which you think
is going to happen
i don't know between those two if those
are the only two choices those are the
only two choices you got
because i honestly think those are both
really really low oh yeah i believe i
agree i agree the probability of this
happening
is like she'd take vp that's it yeah
yeah i don't think she'd replace him as
a candidate okay
uh because he's a shield
it was take the vp and then biden dies
that was actually the that's part of it
the first choice
yeah you gotta say the whole thing oh
and then yeah no i don't think i don't
think
if it was between those two it would she
would take vp and then he would and then
he would die
yeah but i don't think so i think it'll
be like a cheney bush thing yeah
where it's like you know clearly the vp
is you know pulling the strings and
running the show and you get some you
know here's what i said they're going to
do listen i want you to imagine this
joe biden's in a wheelchair okay they
put a blanket on his lap
his head is down and he's just like
snoring and muttering and they wheel him
in
and he's one and they bring him to the
you know the
the back room by the sun you know they
put him up against the window and
there's a
nice little sun beam on his lap and he's
warm and cozy and falls asleep picturing
it and then hillary
sits in the in the in the oval at the
resolute desk
yep and it's like and he just stays
asleep the whole time right yeah i can
see that
yeah i picture it the dude can't be
president and so it's funny because
when like uh like uh we've heard it over
and over again from tons of
different people about joe biden's
mental mental health from progressives
from conservatives
everybody knows everybody everybody does
yeah
everybody it's it's it's it's like the
reminds me of legend of zelda it's a
secret to everybody
you remember that that that saying from
the original zelda game
so you the first one the very first
zelda game okay there were like certain
areas where you could put a bomb in
front of like a mountain
yeah and then you'd walk in and there's
like a dude and he says it's a secret to
everybody
and then he gives you money and it's
like a secret way to get rupees okay for
like buying stuff
dope and i'm like what that means to me
is
everyone knows that biden can't be the
president
okay except biden
i think you've been eating he knows i
think he knows
maybe that's what it is like
as much as most of us are open about it
i think all the resistance people
they know it and they're they're
pretending and that's what i think it's
like it's a secret to everyone it's like
the secret is
that they're planning on stopping out
joe biden yeah everybody knows but
everyone's kind of like
looking at each other you know shifty
eyed is that like the elephant in the
room
basically the elephant in the room yeah
so no no one wants to talk about but
it's
so blaringly obvious kind of but the
elephant room is like there's a big
problem that no one wants to address
like it's uh how is that
no this is a pretty big problem he can't
be president
his mind is slipping because his ass is
slipping they're putting them there on
purpose
that's why i think it's different okay
like they've they've put they've propped
him up and
it's so it's it's not it's it's kind of
like they could maybe work elephant in
the room
but i think it's more so that we all
know there is a game afoot
yeah clearly and we we had that woman
the director of communication say
on uh what show was that on uh was it
fox
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was bill hemmer
she said
that's his name right i'm not sure not
sure what you're referring to right
fox news is america's newsroom bill is
that i think so yeah google
yeah yeah thank you appreciate it uh she
said
we are not officially nominating joe
biden to defeat donald trump
and everybody you like was like whoa did
she just admit it
yeah because what does that what does
that mean yeah what does that mean so
you're nominating to defeat
himself to defeat to be who he's going
against donald trump or is she straight
up saying we're not choosing biden to go
up against trump yeah
she said that the convention must happen
because we are not officially nominating
joe biden to defeat donald trump
something like i'm
i'm paraphrasing i remember the full
quote but it's something like that yeah
and so
the argument is like to be fair maybe
she's saying
we're not only nominating joe biden just
to defeat trump but why wouldn't she say
it that way i agreed
it sounded like she was saying she knows
it ain't gonna be biden and i think deep
down we all know it too oh yeah
especially after the fart joe biden
farted
yes in case you missed it i think deep
down we all know man
oh yeah i think so yeah so
i don't know i think it's always funny
to talk about hillary clinton
potentially running because everyone
hates their guts but let's be real man
everybody hates her i know what are the
dece what is what are they thinking what
are the dems thinking i don't think
it'll be do they think that
that's gonna work nothing they do i feel
can work
right now dude they're they're backed
into a corner they
should just sit in the corner and just
let's stay there for a while and
recollect their thoughts let's go back
to 2008 right okay barack obama
celebrity candidate yeah charismatic
strong
youthful man he had it a lot of people
really liked this guy
and then he did you know really
authoritarian expanse
expanding like wow national defense
authorization act indefinite detention
provisions
extrajudicial assassinations fisa spying
like wow he had it all spying on
journalists
prosecuting more whistleblowers than all
other presidents combined
and still and still got all the left to
love him the whole time he got real
yeah but he was a celebrity right
exactly and and they loved it
but think about so his re-election mitt
romney what is mitt romney fart noise
so so obama still had it you know i
think trump's
trump's approval rating is higher than
obama's was at the same time in his
first term
but then look at 2016 what did the
democrats have to offer after obama
it was like was it like martin o'malley
or something was the guy's name oh gosh
i don't remember it was like two people
putting me on it was like two people in
hillary and then
they like dr but then bernie pops up out
of nowhere right and created
chaos i only remember bernie yeah bernie
steps up
but even without bernie why didn't the
democrats have any nominees
it really felt like in 2008 hillary was
like
look that people thought she was going
to win and then obama came in and took
it away
so then she she you know she gets a role
in
you know obama's administration then
come to the 2015 2015
uh 2016 cycle which includes 2015. yeah
the democratic candidates were like some
randos no one
knew or cared about there was no
personality there was no plan it was
just
hillary yeah and people hate her yes
they really do man like the basket of
deplorables thing i tried to watch her
documentary
i forced me and ian were talking about
like we need to just force ourselves
to watch this and see what it's about
and they like the first thing is like
man
everyone hates her why what what is it
about it
and then they're like it's such a puff
piece it's insane i couldn't watch it
anymore
i had to shut it off i was like i can't
i can't do it i can't do it kill me now
yeah
like we mentioned this the other day
where they did the the the debate
between trump and hillary but gender
swapped it
oh yeah that's right and then like man i
i've watched i watched a clip of it
and seeing the guy be hillary i'm like i
don't like him i don't like that person
so what's what's fascinating is the
primary in michigan yeah
it was uh with bernie sanders and joe
biden and joe biden
crushed sweeping everything this is bad
news for trump
the bernie people thought they would win
michigan because they beat hillary there
last time
but that just shows you how much people
really really hated hillary when you
listen to hillary talk
she talks like someone who feels
entitled to
everybody's worship
almost like do you don't worship me
do you know the story yeah seriously you
know the story about her
uh on like some air force like
cargo plane or something no what is it
there was like i don't know the full
story so i could be getting it totally
wrong but someone
i read this somewhere that like she's on
this air force jet
or plane or something okay and there's a
bunch of air force servicemen crewman
and then she's sitting there reading and
she takes her like wine glass and goes
and holds it up whoo and then there's
like these
like they're military guys they're like
you know i don't know what rank they are
but like they're not
nobodies and they're like what what are
you doing and then she goes
again yeah and like apparently the guy
came up and refilled her drink for her
wow so i heard that because like some
guy wrote a book i don't know if it's
true or not
so you know factor me but the i think
stories like that
we would absolutely want to believe true
but we we we want to believe it because
it really does seem like it fits her
personality
yeah you're like this like you will get
me a drink
that's what people don't like about her
but true look at the primary
what people don't realize is one of the
things that got trump a victory was how
much they despised hillary
that's true trump won some states by
only a few thousand votes
so the people who think that that biden
can't win
that hubris i think things have changed
yeah trump's approval rating has gone up
i mean i i wouldn't i was i considered
myself democrat
for the longest time i mean i don't
consider myself a republican
right but i'm gonna vote for trump i
don't want some rando
i don't want hillary biden yeah i
definitely don't want hillary
yeah man so it's like they got me to
change my mind i just i don't like any
of them
i don't mind watching trump on the tv
makes me laugh but as a president it's
not my it's not my choice
considering now they've placed biden up
against them now they've actually got
like
you're playing metal gear style the
exclamation point that's what happened
when they were like biting i was like
right it's like look trump i think or
whenever he talks at all
same biden yeah yeah fart
it's happening again yeah when trump
talks i laugh and
and sometimes i face palm like the joe
have you seen the joe scarborough tweets
no uh he's been tweeting like
relentlessly about
msnbc joe scarborough because like in
2000
an intern working for scarborough was
found dead in his uh his office or
whatever oh geez couple months later he
resigns
and it's like it's like a a big
conspiracy like people think was a
cover-up
and i'm just like i don't know anything
about it man
i get it uh people are concerned about
corruption and like you know this guy
getting away with it
he was a republican yikes and trump
keeps tweeting about it
over and over again and i'm just like
dude look when you rag on cnn and jim
acosta i'm laughing
i really am because i'm like these
people are they kind of deserve it
well it's it's like deserve
all right right yeah they're just bad
people who make a mockery of journalism
who are lying all day and joe
scarborough has a lot of issues
for sure he's actually said some uh
complimentary things towards trump
you know he's just another guy with his
opinion and it's one thing if trump came
out and tweeted something like joe
scarborough said this he's totally wrong
what a [ __ ]
i'd laugh but when he starts bringing up
stuff from 20 years ago about like some
conspiracy stuff i'm like dude you're
not arguing about it
that's what i don't like about the
democrats they say trump is bad
trump is racist and i'm like those
aren't arguments that you're not telling
me anything
right so if trump wants to come out and
complain about msnbc he's not telling me
anything
i don't know what i'm supposed to i'm
supposed to feel about that i'm like i
don't dude i don't know
what you think is going to happen with
joe scarborough yeah i feel you so
it's like yeah so anyway i digress
the main point was trump has
vulnerabilities
and then according to the new york times
his base is bigger than ever
his favorability is way up and he's got
a higher approval rating or he did i
should say in the last gallup poll
than uh obama and bush for the same time
period i think clinton's was higher
but clinton did dip in in a certain
period so that
it bodes well for trump but when you
take into consideration how much people
hated hillary clinton
you might get a bunch of passive like we
mentioned like these leftists who don't
these liberals whatever you want to call
them who don't read the news or anything
and they're just like no trump and so
you think about that person
and you think about hillary clinton and
donald trump and they're looking at
hillary clinton uh
and they're hitting like trump over and
over again and then you look at today
and they see trump and biden they go oh
biden it's like obama yeah
that's what that dude said on the rogan
podcast was his name tim dillon was that
tim dillon that was um
oh crap i can't i think it was right
yeah yeah he said he said
people are going to vote for biden
because it gives them nostalgia to the
obama years
that's why every single time biden was
debating anyone first thing he would say
is well
when me and obama were you know obama
it's like yeah every other word was
obama it's like saying obama
abiding bombing yes yeah man
i don't know what that was frustrating
we'll see what's going to happen you
know we can speculate in politics all
day night thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you